let's go next to our caller from the 919
area code nine
now 919 is that north carolina maybe
no it's country code 91 i'm sorry who's
calling from country code 91.
hello david it's me uh i'm from india
aniket from india love it okay yes
what's going on my friend
hello yeah so i was just gonna ask you
about um
i don't know if you talked about this
but uh you know the recent comments by
trump about calling fallen soldiers
um you know suckers and losers yeah
that the military vote will will
decrease because of that because
i saw a segment by you
i saw a segment but you were in on the
bonus show we were talking with pat
about how the military isn't really that
um uh republican and do you think that
this will just even decrease your
support by voters in the military
i do think so i i don't know that it's
going to be a big impact but
i think that you know we have that
military times poll from a week or two
ago
pointing out that right now members of
the military are leaning biden
by about six points i have to believe
that even if it's not a huge
impact overall that a few more
point percentage points of military
members are going to get away from trump
because
of the quadruply corroborated story
that he called members of the military
who died
suckers and losers i think it will
affect him
in terms of his support within the
military by a little bit at least
yeah and do you think of us as like more
psychopathic followers they're just
going to live in denial about this yeah
with everything else yeah yeah the
sycophantic followers will just say
it didn't happen and they'll continue
living you know living their lives and
supporting trump for sure
yeah that's uh crazy all right thank you
david for taking my call
wait so hold on a second so what what
part of india do you live in
oh i live in south southeast india i
live in davangana
and what is life like there
uh well i guess they're they're copying
the us's idea of the pandemic is over
we're not going to do anything further
and
okay i guess if you want to take care of
yourself you just wear a mask
and um yeah i just had to actually i had
to go out to take a picture of
the sunsets on my physics lab
and you can just see like everything's
normal no one's uh
i think some people are wearing masks
but if you just came in
and you had no idea what's going on you
wouldn't you wouldn't think anything
other than
yeah i guess people are just wearing
masks more now
and it did you have you lived in an
english-speaking country or is your your
language proficiency
simply from learning english in india
oh yeah my language proficiency is
simply from learning language in india
that's unbelievable going to an
university in the states
but um that is incredible but i couldn't
because i have to
okay yeah yeah so i am going to
university in the states but i have to
stay here because of coven
so i hope i guess in the spring i would
be going uh
but yeah all right well listen i really
appreciate the phone call it's great to
hear from viewers all over the world
yeah i'd love to hear from you and
congratulations on 990
000 subscribers david yes 9.90 is nice 1
million i think will be a nice round
number though
let's go all right thanks so much
appreciate the phone call thank you
wow caller from india love it